and opening this game up for the tampa
bay ray is going to be right-hander
aaron slager's his fourth game with the
raise the era of 11.25 that was really
one outing against the boston red sox
where he had some tough luck hits
now travis shaw and he takes care of
shaw
pitch breaking down and in but over his
last three starts he's allowed just two
runs over 17 innings he's really
put everything together lately brandon
loud steps in it
and a weak ground ball back towards the
mound ryu has it into first in time and
he gets the raise
in order
that's gonna be strike three call nicely
done there
so two down and wendell at first on the
fielder's choice the batter manuel
margot the center fielder tonight
back-to-back change-ups and a ground
ball to short panic
in time to get margot and to retire the
side
the one-on-one nobody out panic hitting
176 on the year
and that is strike three nice pitch on
the inside
corner now the hitter will be the
catcher reese maguire
popped up left side wendell
near the line still fair and he's got it
for the out we're going to go back
to the top of the order kevin biggio a
little looper into shallow right center
field
with the adamus a couple of steps back
onto the outfield turf is there
to make the catch and it's another nice
inning for aaron slegers
brasso who struck out his first time on
one hopper to short backhanded by panic
and onto first in time a good play for
joe panic
he's pitching very effectively using
both sides of the plate getting some bad
contact and
and i mean you're not going to find
anything wrong with that line
here's travis shaw and he strikes out
shaw
fastball up jose martinez the batter he
is the proud owner of the only hit in
this game good job
and he strikes him out a great four
inning so far for hunjin ryu
sean gilmartin will follow him to the
mound with vladimir guerrero jr
leading off the fifth and he walks
guerrero to begin the fifth inning so
already encouraging signs for the blue
jays after not doing anything
against slaggers so the bases are loaded
so now it'll be up to cabin visio
up and in for ball four and that'll
force in a run as the blue jays take the
lead
and gretchek will be the hitter ground
ball left side
wendell's got it throw to first and the
damage limited
to just one run the razor first and
third with nobody out a chance
to tie this game with a base hit or
maybe even a ground up we'll chop out to
second biggio to panic one
first base not in time and the run
scores
so the rays get on the board and tie the
game they answer the run at the top of
the fifth with a run here
in the bottom so an immediate threat
here by toronto
vladimir guerrero jr chop right side
down to second one throw to first
they're gonna get
two thompson over there to cover
the bag at first and over to third goes
shaw
first and third orders guriel jr will be
the hitter ariel the ground ball back to
the mound on that first pitch and a toss
to first
will take care of the blue jays a 1-1
tie bottom six and the top of the order
mike brasso is up
and a swing and a miss at a 96 mile an
hour fastball one down
utter red and fro will be the batter
right on the corner great pitch there
from font back to back strikeouts
steal second base
[Applause]
swinging in a mess ball pops away headed
toward the dugout
runner is going to try to score in the
throw to the plate he is
out with fairbanks covering viggio
trying to catch the raise there and they
cut him down at the plate as that
straight three got away from zanino
tied at one two men on two men out in
the seventh inning facing
yoshi tsutsugo and delivers a fastball
on the inside corner strike three call
97 miles an hour to ring up to go
guriel calls the free pass and the
go-ahead run is aboard
and the ground ball down to first out
there tag is on its second
and out there as well adamus puts the
tag on guriel
swinging in a miss maguire maguire's out
on strikes
he spot that slider down and away to the
right hand hitting margot right here
a bouncer to short and the inning is
over
how about more baseball the blue jays
are going extra innings again
that's a fair ball out and second
and the rays get the double play but at
least he got him at third base
and now g-man choi will
they've decided they're going to send
choi down to first they will not pitch
to him
and kevin kiermeier will come off the
raised bench to bat for rousseau
and a base hit lined into left that
drops in front of guriel jr
and the rays are going to win it margot
scores
and the rays went in 10. it's a 2-1
final tiermeyer on the first pitch
walks it off and the rays win in 10.